I want to remind you this word yeah
you've met it before
do you remember what context we do what
these are binary could you give me an
example when you see the Preferences by
like bicycle okay
where you got two things where we saw
this before was things like saying this
you don't have to write this down then
he's trying to jog your memory okay
something like this
do you remember we had a look at these
when we're in the topic absurds we
looked at these because they were
particularly interesting when you expand
everything out lots of these are like
terms and they simplify quite nicely it
is which bit is a binomial because the
whole thing is not a binomial which
parts whether they're actually two of
them do you see he is one that's a by
mojo okay because look is this end this
two weeks and then here is the other one
one negative root five
those are the two pieces that make the
buy menu so binomials are and I'd love
this underneath the hedges so you have
your media by littles are combinations
of two terms you can combine two terms
in lots of different ways and lots of
different kinds of terms as well so if
you have a Viper you're like many no
this is your 12 I'm sorry that's eat
well this is your 10 we don't have your
table today are you thinking of no no
their minds
oh that's something about me yeah
we buy their news we know this is
binomial this is a binary so this is a
binary your product something times
something
are you with me so far yes okay so you
know what these are
yeah I know what these are what topic
are we in right now what kinds of things
have you been dealing with recently
we've within indices but indices with
what we didn't do indices like this
fraction we did indices like this
products and factors are to do with
algebra that's what we move yeah okay so
we're gonna look at binary products
without reading them okay so I want you
to have a look at a series of okay now
we've seen these before
I need another column we have we have
some things have something else this is
just like the expanding and factorizing
we were doing last lesson except it's
just a little more difficult because
both of these things in my memories okay
if you have another column there in fact
I want to remind you of how we do this
we go from here we multiply by these two
once you've multiplied a by both terms
then you multiply one by both terms do
you see that see I've gone through so
let's actually go ahead and do this
let's just crunch the numbers okay
[Music]
let's do the green ones first up the top
when I expand for the first bit you're
going to do any multiply by B which
gives you may be able to put my 5 which
gives you finish it off for me ok are
you happy with that can we simplify any
better
well it's expanded if it were necessary
and I lost you I could factorize it I
could go back how would you do that
button doesn't actually the question of
interest and benefit how would you do it
Jennifer
ok so you can just reverse this process
right you instead of getting rid of the
brackets you start to add something you
might notice oh look
those have a common factor 5 these have
a common factor B and you can take them
out and you will come back to where we
started okay so that's not what I'm
interested in doing but what I want to
point out to you is there's a really
nice visual way of understanding what is
going on which is by thinking of this
something times something else kind of
like what you first learned will do this
multiplication okay way back in
parameter I wonder if you ever saw it
like this you draw this for me have you
did do you recognize this when you say 2
times 5 what it really means is look
there's two lots of five this way or if
you like is five lots of to this way
does that make sense and it's one of the
nice ways that you can convince yourself
and remember the two times five and five
times two at the same key because we
need to do is just kind of look at it
and then turn your head and you can see
once 225 the other is five times two
okay in other words we try to represent
a product with a picture it's like it's
like a grid sort of thing I can do the
same
over here it's just that this is what
I've got help me out if you got a ruler
there this will be useful join yourself
a horizontal line and I want you to
imagine that this horizontal line is
made up of two bins part of it is a like
this part over here and then the other
part next to it is one so you've got a
and one and you jammed together to make
one interval then the total length is a
plus 1 right there you just added them
does that make sense
now a plus 1 is one ingredient B plus 5
is the other now just making up legs by
the way it doesn't matter how long these
are it's just a picture B plus 5 let's
call that something like this okay so
what are we looking at
just like here you had the kind of like
a grid shape you can make a grid shape
over here as well right I'm just going
to complete the other sides and when you
expanded you got out
one two three four objects well this
diagram here also has the same 1 2 3 4
objects if you put in that credo is
talking about I'm gonna put a line
across and then I'm gonna put a line
down this way ok have a look at what we
have to bring okay look at the top-left
corner it's a rectangle and you know its
width and you know its height the area
rectangle is just width times height so
what's its area just like it it's just a
me right what about this one over here
it's 1 times B so it's just hey do you
agree
how about this one don't you
Hey and then this one here is fine times
one which is fine so you see what we
wrote down here by going one two three
four four is just what you've
represented just in a shape okay so this
isn't binomial product this is a
binomial a plus one this is another
binomial B plus five and that's why you
get all these four pieces out okay